ouais
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui on est à genève
c'est le grand départ pour le csa las
vegas alors c'était un peu la galère
parce que hier j'ai pris le train et
éboulements sur la voie en plus
l'aéroport international à new york a
été fermée j'espère qu'aujourd'hui il
été réouvert donc normalement a priori
c'est bon parce que tous les vols au
départ de genève hier et du moins on
sait d'ailleurs ont été annulés pour new
york
donc sans couche pour être un peu dans
la merde donc normalement ça devrait pas
trop trop mal se passer sur ce coup ci
c'est la journée de la presse hier un
mot airbnb à new york c'est annulé moins
de 24 heures la dre il a fallu trouver
un hôtel de remplacement je vous raconte
pas comment en plus dans le bus j'ai
manqué de faire vomir tu pourras gamme
enfin voir lire c'était la poisse
aujourd'hui six mois ça sera mieux parce
que là on bat à new york et après on
parlait de guest ocs
[Musique]
vous voyez bien mais là vous avez
manhattan bridge
j'ai vu ce devant derrière il ya le
brooklyn bridge et tout au fond derrière
il ya la statue galibert et là on est
donc effectivement sur la partie basse
de manhattan
il est 8h30 du matin dimanche matin
c'est calme ya pas un rat une dame là
bas cuvée qui fait du ce qu'il faut
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
du conseil
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour faire une
petite faq c'est vrai on a déjà parlé je
voulais demander alors on va faire
sauter faq tout de suite vous avez posé
des questions excusez moi je fais super
super froid là il sait quelque chose
comme combien il fait moins 12 fait
super froid alors je vous avais demandé
de me poser des questions pour la faq
savoir ce que vous voulez savoir pas
savoir qui vous intéressez vous
intéressez pas donc on va faire ça la
première fois qu et on l'a fait avec une
vue sur manhattan sur le brooklyn bridge
enfin moins 12 degrés c'est génial
question de baptiste est ce que tu vas
changer de téléphone
j'aimerais bien mais ces trucs là ça
coûterait moins relativement cher j'ai
réussi dans une nouvelle caméra donc là
pour l'instant le changement de
téléphone s'est pas encore trop prévu as
tu un travail à côté de la chaîne
youtube il faut rentrer un peu d'argent
parce que pour l'instant la chaîne
youtube ça ramène pas beaucoup d'argent
ça paye
à peine les frais notamment les frais du
voyage qui coûte quand même relativement
cher huawei g1 ses activités à côté je
crée des sites web
j'écris aussi pour un magazine pour de
l'aviation j'écris des chroniques pour
eux
et puis je suis un petit peu de ventes
en extra de temps en temps histoire de
renflouer les casse mais pour moi l'acte
il était principal c'est la chaîne
youtube
c'est là dessus que je mais c'est
vraiment ce que je veux faire donc c'est
pour ça aussi que je pompe sont tués en
couple et tu as quel âge puis qu'est-ce
qui t'a donné envie de commencer youtube
alors je suis beaucoup plus ça va faire
bientôt dix ans quel âge - 38 je me
rapproche tranquillement des 40 pour
l'instant je suis encore se prend encore
le temps de rester dans la trentaine
qu'est ce qui m'a donné envie de
commencer youtube un au départ en fin de
compte j'avais un blog monsieur gros
point fr sur lequel j'écrivais des trucs
un peu marrant fin du mois ce qui moi me
faisait marrer
et puis l'idée envie de réaliser des
vidéos ça faisait très longtemps que
j'avais envie d'en faire j'essaye de la
prod vidéo j'avais une boîte de prod
vidéo à une époque
et puis voilà je sais plus trop de
vidéos ça me manquait c'était dommage
donc je suis libre pourquoi pas faire ce
qui me fait marrer en vidéo
donc j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos en
plus généraliste un peu vlog un peu
rigolote et puis au final je me suis
vraiment plus tôt ce message est dans
quelque chose qui me passionnait qui
m'intéressait à savoir la itech donc
voilà je me suis vraiment mis là dedans
j'ai eu du retour ça vous a intéressé
donc j'ai continué et puis je m'épanouis
ya dedans et c'est génial ce qu'ils
aient mois pour les défendeurs situation
mais c'est hyper froid chocolatines ou
pas en chocolat
c'est quoi ces conneries de chocolatines
ta marque audio préféré ma marque audio
préférées il y en a énormément qui sont
super bien je n'ai pas tout essayé
j'adore sony alors audio pour mon casque
en tout cas moi j'utilise un vieux
casque sony un des 75 06 c'est vraiment
un vieux truc mais qui reste quand même
une référence donc sony j'adore j'aime
pas trop les casques beats je trouve
qu'il ya trop trop grave le son est pas
génial le médium est pas très très beau
en tout cas pour l'instant de ce que
j'essayais sûr que vraiment sony reste
vrai manque des produits de super
qualité
quel est l'objet high tech que tu
voudrais acheter en priorité bientôt
soir il y en a tellement c'est compliqué
les enceintes connectés ça me botte
vraiment alors je sais pas encore ce que
je prendrais est ce que le home pote
d'apple peut être intéressant le
problème c'est que c'est pareil c'est
relativement cher amazon amazon et alexa
ça me tente bien en plus ils sont
vraiment connecté avec pas mal
d'appareils souffre énormément je pense
qu'un vrai moyen des choses super sympa
il ya aussi des lunettes de réalité
augmentée avec amazon alexandre et pas
mal de choses à voir là dessus donc je
pense que c'est vraiment ce qui va me
passionner je pense que c'est vraiment
le truc sur lequel je vais me diriger
est ce que tu as des enfants vrai j'ai
un petit garçon elliott 88 qui passe son
temps à dire un caca boudin caca prout
18 fès le boss janot qu'est ce qu'un
rapport qualité prix dans le domaine de
la téléphonie mobile
ça c'est ces questions un peu compliqué
le rapport qualité prix c'est qu'est-ce
que vous allez avoir comme qualité par
rapport au budget vous allez y mettre
donc à un moment il y a
espèce de basculement plus vous allez
mettre mieux vous allez avoir de qualité
normalement donc un moment et moi vous
allez mettre à contrario moins la
qualité va être bonne donc le bon
rapport qualité prix correspond
notamment à votre budget et aux choses
que vous allez pouvoir à voir avec votre
budget après c'est dépendant de chacun
pour moi les produits moyen de gamme
vous autour des 400 500 euros aux hommes
un super rapport qualité prix avec des
qualités quasiment haut de gamme et pas
sur les prix du haut de gamme voilà pour
cette première faq à new york city avec
verrière manhattan downtown manhattan
si vous voulez on pourrait faire une
prochaine effectué à las vegas et
quelques jours normalement j'aurais
moins de mal articulé il fera beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus chaud donc ça devrait
aller mieux
laissez-moi toutes vos questions en
dessous de cette vidéo si vous en avez
d'autres je le ferais un plaisir d'y
répondre
[Musique]